we solved yesterday PGA Tour taking some
action what's happened in Greater
Hartford Open where you've had some
players and caddies who have left the
tournament and that includes Webb
Simpson and his caddie is Paul
two-storey who joins us now on the
program Paul thanks for joining us so
what happened how long were you in
Hartford and when did you realize that
your week was going to end a little
sooner than you expected yeah so flew up
Monday afternoon we were fortunate
enough to win last week on the PGA Tour
and head and came home for half a day
and flew up and Tuesday was a very very
normal day as the day progressed or
starting to hear some rumblings of some
tests that had maybe come back not the
way we had hoped and the first one we
heard was Cameron champ a young twenty
six-year-old on tour bomber who had
tested positive and so he was out of the
tournament and then as as the day kind
of progressed were standing on the
putting green and we had heard some
other rumors about there was another
positive test and as we're sitting there
Webb gets a phone call and finds out
someone of his family had tested
positive for code 19 and so you know
there we are on the putting green
obviously got a lot of people around and
immediately we start going into a
different mode as far as Webber and I
trying to decide if what do I need to do
instantly right now - while we decide so
we left the putting green we went and
contacted the PGA Tour's started to have
discussions with them what's the
protocol of this point going forward
obviously Webb had been exposed because
he's been with his daughter during the
significant amount of time and it's
impossible to know Webb took a test
Tuesday and Wednesday morning negative
on both of them but he just felt like to
protect the tournament to make sure more
than any web Smith in the world right
now is leading the FedEx Cup and the
last thing you want I think is kind of
one of those names taking even though
it's a small chance taking a chance of
infecting anybody else so he made the
decision to withdraw when did you get
tested so we test f starting this week
well we're tested every day when you
come
it's just a Tuesday morning and
Wednesday morning me personally
same with Weber Tuesday and Wednesday
generally all you are is when you come
in and you register if that's on a
Sunday Monday or Tuesday you're tested
and then you're only tested again when
you're leading the golf tournament to go
on the Charter to be a Saturday
I know Commissioner Monahan yesterday
talked about we're gonna change that a
little bit we're gonna up it up at least
one more test per week
just to make sure that we keep everybody
safe how is your job different with
these new rules there's a lot of things
that are different the older we get
we're all creatures of habit and so so
many things are just very natural to you
whether it's the the handshake in golf
is you know really faint we see at
basketball and other sports as well with
a handshake that's obviously gone but
you know the tour doesn't want us even
fist bumping just no contact if you can
and so I think that's the number one as
far as caddie player it's tough we try
to stay six feet apart by keeping the
golf bag in between us but I read greens
with Webb so there's several occasions
where I'm gonna be inside that six foot
zone not for long periods of time
probably between five and ten seconds
but you know as far as that's concerned
he's been tested and tested we're clean
and we're not going outside that bubble
at all during the week and I think
that's the big part that the tour is
really battling right now is we meaning
caddies and players we have to do our
job and it's getting better each week
the first week was not very good and we
got some pretty stern warnings from the
tour guys we have to do this well we got
the world watching us but also we don't
want to shut down the second week but
now guys are starting a little scared
we've had four positive tests and we've
done 2,800 test so for still a very very
low number but guys are seeing the
ramifications now of what's happening
number four and clearing a little bird
tuck it has to go home fifth right
player in the world Webb says it has to
go home and you know that might just be
the start of something to scare the guys
enough to make sure they stay safe
he's Webb Simpson Skadi Paul to sori who
joins us on the program could players
carry their own bags at some point here
so I'm gonna say no I'm gonna make fun
of the players first you know deli golf
is a little cool
it used to be at one point we've got
some pretty pretty talented athletes
playing golf nalli this is the Tiger
generation that we see you got these
kids coming out 6-3 6-4 big broad
shoulders so the answer is they could
the answer from this guy's standing by
nicely here in the backyard that I have
because Webb's great play DJ's great
play has paid for a lot of the stuff
that I'm sitting at right now so I hope
not I don't think it'll come to that
again I was gonna say if if we do our
job
obviously if Commissioner Monahan
sitting back and he's looking at week
after week after week if he's watching
players and caddies a foot from each
other then he may be rushed to a
decision that they you know I have to
stop that for a little while but the
players would not do a great job and
they would have no money to blame you
know if they hit a bad shot somebody
there nobody there to blame I always let
me miss a putt mate always look at the
caddie I do not think we will see that I
was also wondering about now is the time
to play against Tiger Woods because guys
talk about the galleries that surround
Tiger in it it's just something you
can't prepare for like there's no
gallery how weird is it that there's
there's no response no reaction no
nothing science it's completely strange
at Hilton Head I watched the one player
world Rory McIlroy make a 35-foot on his
last hole today and nothing on a clap
from anybody
now one clap from media obviously or
anybody else around and that was strange
and then coming down the stretch on
Sunday at Hilton Head I think one thing
you saw is for the first time in my life
I've never seen so many different
players make so many birdies down the
stretch there was seven to nine guys
that were just pouring in putts from
everywhere hitting it flows and I do
think the fans have a little bit of do
that I talked to web web said he said he
felt the same while I understand him
meaning that I do think there's a
difference if you're coming down the
last three holes with 50,000 people
yelling and screaming versus no one
there has to be a little bit less
because
response to that and I think we saw that
by the caliber of play down the stretch
last week what's your favorite Tiger
Woods story oh I got a bunch of them you
know I'm the tiger who guy that wore the
stupid hat and so he hasn't explained
yes caddy working for Vijay Singh and
Vijay was the only guy that held back
time from when the Grand Slam that year
Vijay won the Masters Tiger won the next
three playing the Presidents Cup we've
played against Tiger every match the
United States team is blowing out the
international team I was with B John the
international team and so we get paired
with tied in elastic ball guys have some
hats that say tiger who I think it's
hilarious Vijay thinks it's hilarious we
where we're on the fourth hole and Vijay
has to two-putt from nine feet and
there's crickets you hear nothing and
you look over there on the side and
Tiger standing like this with his arms
crossed a scowl on his face so Vijay
putts it down to it's hanging over the
hole I'm not embellishing the hanging
over the hole we sit there long enough
it would have gone in we hear crickets
again we look back over and he still got
his arms crossed and the scowl and Tiger
loves the story now so we're definitely
not ruining any kind of inside scoop and
BJ looked at me he goes I don't think he
likes the Hat
so as we tacked it in from a millimeter
away for par to win the hole to go to up
Tiger had not played well that week
Notah Begay had covered him all week and
on the next hole Tiger turned a little
more hit about 305 yard one yard draw
7-under on his last 13 story is that
tiger I had never really talked about it
and it weren't Sean O'Haire played a lot
of practice rounds with me but i was
working for weber in 2011 and tiger was
walking by let's turn to webber like you
know it's weird I still feel like
there's just that little something there
with him and I and I wish there wasn't
it was meant as a joke not disrespect
and he won't buy us and what's up tiger
who he said what's up two in one
people walked about another 20 yards you
turned around with that big grin that
we've gotten used to see any laugh but
you have to think about that he probably
thought of two and one every time he saw
me because there was no time lapse
between when I said what's up tiger hoon
2 & 1 and then this year the Presidents
Cup for picture day he got everybody
where Paul who owned the to pay me back
so that's probably my favorite I have
got a ton of them he has he's both
helped me build nice houses and places
to live and he's also taken a lot of we
all as fans get to see the new Tiger
Woods you know I think we're seeing the
tiger woods after obviously golf humbled
it a little bit but also with kids now
kids change all of us so it's great to
see how joyful he is now on the golf
course most famous person you've either
caddy for or played golf with so
definitely President Clinton when he was
in office he gained the Milosevic
indictment trial from the front gate at
white oak plantation and we played with
him five straight days it was some of
the best times I had in my entire life
you could give him crap and he loved it
he loved the more junk you talked to him
the better he liked it so that would be
it and then next would probably be
playing with Michael Jordan I was able
fortunate to play nine holes with him
and and just ask a lot of stories and he
took a little money from me at the end
of it and that was the set of that well
it feels like you have to give him money
to get the story Paul you paid for those
stories just so you know hey before I
let you go I know that you have the two
story family foundation and it's
certainly important and close to your
heart and I wanted to give you an
opportunity to talk about that
yeah thank you I'll just keep it brief
but you're our foundation we started in
2010 we've been able to give back a
little over one and a half million to
the local communities and a little bit
throughout the country as well we put on
these all-star kids clinics for kids
with special needs 25 kids one on one
instruction so check us out - sorry
Family Foundation org and anyway you can
help us we welcome it thank you for
joining us on short notice and our best
to web who you know once he figured out
putting again he's
I'm announcing and Congrats on the win
at Hilton Head man I appreciate thanks
for having me on everybody stay safe
that's Paul - sorry he's Webb Simpson
Scott